(upbeat music)
I am dying to show you this!
Take a look.
Hi Drew! We're the Craft Grooms.
Let's run to Dollar Tree and grab some supplies
before they run out and make mom a fall table centerpiece.
We'll start by hot gluing rope around the base.
Then taking the flower foam and adding that,
then staple gun and then hot glue that metal pumpkin frame.
Look at me, I'm Cinderella. I'm in a pumpkin.
Then hire your local florist or the husband,
the other Craft Groom in my case,
and make it beautiful
and then wrap some rope around the top and hot glue it.
Add some leaves and there you go.
Hey mom, we hope you love your fall table centerpiece
and you too, Drew.
Hey, when can we eat?
Love, Craft Grooms.
I can't wait to try that!
(upbeat music)